"
MARK: WELCOME BACK.
GLENN YOUNGKIN, VERY
INTERESTING, JOE BIDEN RAN
AS A CANDIDATE WHO SAID HE
WOULD UNIFY AMERICA.
YOU SEEM TO BE UNIFYING THE
CITIZENS OF VIRGINIA.
EVEN DEMOCRATS.
WHO APPEAR TO PUT THEIR
CHILDREN IN QUALITY
EDUCATION AHEAD OF THIS
BIZARRE IDEA OL.
>> I, AND TERRY MCCAULIFFE
DENIES IT IS TAKING PLACE.
WE CONTINUE IS.
-- WE KNOW IT IS.
WE HAD BRINGING IN A CONGA
LINE OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
RADICAL, SUPPORT CRITICAL
RACE THEORY.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF HIM
BRINGING IN THE CAREER
POLITICIANS?
>> IT IS THE CLEAR PLAYBOOK
THAT TERRY MCCAULIFFE WROTE,
HE REALLY IS THE GODFATHER
OF MODERN DAY PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THAT IS WHAT HE DOSE, HE
NEEDS TO TAKE SPOTLIGHT OFF
OF FAILED GUBERNATORIAL
CAREER, HE DOES NOT HAVE A
PLAN FOR VIRGINIA.
ALL VIRGINIANS KNOW IT, HE
IS TRYING TO DEFLECT
ATTENTION AWAY FROM HIM, ON
TO ANYONE ELSE.
ANYONE WHO HELD OFFICE OR
RUN FOR OFFICE AND FAILED AS
DEMOCRAT HAS BEEN INVITED TO
COME IN AND CAMPAIGN WITH
TERRY MCCAULIFFE.
VIRGINIANS SEE THROUGH IT,
THEY KNOW IT IS A SHARE
-- CHARADE.
WE'RE ON A 10 DAY BUS
TOUR.
WE SEE THOUSANDS COME
TOGETHER SAYING WE'RE FOR
WHAT YOU STAND FOR GLENN.
A GOVERNMENT THAT WORKS FOR
US, AND STOPS TELLING US
WHAT TO DO.
YET WE'RE SEEING INDEPENDENT
VOTERS VOTE WITH THEIR FEET,
AND MINORITY COMMUNITY,
LATINO COMMUNITY COME STRONG
WITH US.
DEMOCRATS ARE
WALKING ACROSS THE AISLE IN
MASS, THEY WANT A BETTER
VIRGINIA.
GLENN YOUNGKIN WILL WORK
WITH ANYONE TO DELIVER
FUNDAMENTAL KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES.
THIS IS WHAT VIRGINIANS ARE
VOTING FOR, THE VALUES ARE
UNIVERSAL.
THEY ARE NOT PARTY VALUES,
THEY ARE VIRGINIA VALUES, WE
TALK ABOUT VIRGINIA PROMISE
THAT WE CAN DELIVER
TOGETHER, ON THE BALLOT IS
VIRGINIA, TERRY MCCAULIFFE
AND BIG GOVERNMENT CONTROL
AGAINST VIRGINIANS
INDEPENDENCE AND LIBERTY,
THIS IS WHY WE SEE SO MUCH
MOMENTUM, WE RACING BY THEM.
YOU KNOW POLLS DON'T WIN
ELECTIONS, VOTES DO, WE'RE
ENCOURAGING EVERYONE, PLEASE
GET OUT AND VOTE.
GET OUT AND VOTE ON TUESDAY.
AND LET'S STAND UP AS
VIRGINIAIANS.
MARK: MONEY GUY
BETWEEN HILLARY CLINTON AND
DNC.
AND DOSEIOR PUT OUT.
VERY CREEPY, PROBLEMATIC.
IS COLLEAGUE AND PARTNER WAS
INDICTEDDED FOR HIS
ACTIVITIES INVOLVED IN THAT
HE SET UP HIS OWN LAW FIRM,
HUNDREDS OF MILLION IN DARK
MONEY TO COFFERS TO HELP HIM
DEFEAT REPUBLICANS WHO WON
RACES.
ARE YOU CONCERNED ABOUT THIS
EVEN IF YOU SHOULD WIN THAT
McCAULIFFE BECAUSE HE IS
NOT AN UP RIGHT GUY, HE IS
HIRING THIS GUY TO DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO UNDO
THE ELECTION.
>> THIS IS RIGHT OUT OF HIS
PLAYBOOK.
HE WROTE IT, THIS IS WHAT
FAILING POLITICIAN DOES WHEN
THEY SEE THE SUN SETTING ON
THEIR FREE YEAR POLITICAL
CAREER, HE COULD HIRE AS
MANY LAWYERS AS HE WANTS,
VIRGINIA VOTERS ARE MAKING A
BOLD STATEMENT.
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE A
CLOSE ELECTION, YOU CAN SEE
US PULLING AWAY.
YOU CAN SEE US MAKING A
STATEMENT TO NOT JUST WIN
THE GOVERNOR'S RACE BUT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR RACE
WITH WINSTON SEARS AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL RACE, WE'LL
WIN BACK CONTROL OF OUR
HOUSE OF DELEGATES, LOCAL
RACES ALL OVER SHERIFF
RACES, SCHOOL BOARD
RACES, THIS IS A BIG
STATEMENT.
A LAWYER HERE AND THERE THAT
MY OPPONENT HIRES WILL NOT
MAKE A DIFFERENCE, THIS WILL
BE AN OWN WHELMING --
OVERWHELMING VICTORY.
MARK: POLLS ARE POLLS, IF
YOU DON'T TURN OUT AND VOTE,
THE POLLS COULD TURN OUT TO
BE WRONG.
SO IT VERY IMPORTANT ON
ELECTION DAY THAT AN ARMY OF
PATRIOTS TURN OUT AND VOTE.
THIS RACE IS WATCHED ALL
OVER THE NATION, IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND WATCHED BY
SO-CALLED MODERATES IN HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES, AND
SENATE.
I DO WANT TO SAY THIS TO
GLENN YOUNGKIN YOU CAME OUT
OF NOWHERE, YOU HAVE
SACRIFICED YOUR CAREER.
YOU HAVE TO USE A LOTS OF
YOUR OWN MONEY IN THIS
CAMPAIGN TO COUNTER THE
DEMOCRAT MONEY.
YOU HAVE RUN A HELL OF A
CAMPAIGN.
AND YOU BROUGHT QUALITY
EDUCATION TO THE FORE.
SOMETHING I HAVE CARED ABOUT
MY LIFE EQUALITY EDUCATION.
YOU ARE THE CANDIDATE, FOR
ONCE, FINALLY, A REPUBLICAN
HAS TAKEN THAT ISSUE AND RUN
WITH IT.
THE DEMOCRATS DO NOT BELIEVE
IN SCHOOL CHOICE OR QUALITY
EDUCATION OR ANYTHING OF THE
SORT, THEY BELIEVE IN
TEACHERS UNIONS THEY
REPRESENT THEM.
>> THANK YOU.
>> OVER COURSE OF LAST 10
MONTHS WE HAVE AN AMAZING
GROUP OF PEOPLE AROUND US,
THIS IS ABOUT VIRGINIANS,
COMING TOGETHER AROUND A
FELLOW VIRGINIAN, I AM
OPTIMISTIC OF ALL CHANGE WE
COULD BRING, WE'RE STANDING
UP FOR AMERICA.
SO VIRGINIA HAS A CHANCE TO
LEAD LIKE WE HAVE FROM THE
FOUNDING OF THIS GREAT
COUNTRY, WE HAVE TO GET OUT
AND VOTE TUESDAY.
PLEASE COME OUT AND VOTE
COULD MAKE YOUR VOICE HEARD,
AND LET'S MAKE CHANGE HAPPEN
NOT JUST FOR FUTURE OF OUR
GREAT COMMONWEALTH BUT THE
COUNTRY, AND THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR HAVING ME ON YOUR
SHOW.
EVERYONE CAN JOIN US.
LET'S GET THIS DONE.
MARK: FOR MY SAKE AND MY
FAMILY SAKE.
I WISH YOU ALL OF THE BES